[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIELLE BROWN: Super glad
to have Giselle Carino here
with us today.
Giselle as the CEO of
the International Planned
Parenthood Federation in the
Western Hemisphere region.
And today, we really
are going to have
a conversation about the
state of women's health
and the state of women's
rights in the region
and how the International
Planned Parenthood
Federation is
navigating the region's
rapidly-changing
political, economic,
and environmental landscape.
I am delighted to have a
woman leader here today
to talk about this important
issue, so welcome, Giselle.
GISELLE CARINO:
Thank you so much.
Thank you for such
a kind introduction.
Thank you all for joining
this conversation.
Thank you both John and
Louise for making this happen.
It's a great
opportunity to be here.
Coffee is great.
[LAUGHTER]
I look forward to
next opportunity.
Thank you very much.
DANIELLE BROWN: Good.
Well, Giselle, I always like
to start these conversations
with a personal story.
So can you tell us a little bit
about how you got interested
in this work and sort of how
you got to where you are today?
GISELLE CARINO: Well, you
know, I grew up in Argentina,
in rural Argentina.
And when I say
rural, I mean rural.
I remember receiving the
Sunday paper at 4:00 PM.
That's rural.
And I went to an
all-girls Catholic school.
And this is not at all
a comment on faith.
As you just mentioned, we work
with progressive religious
leaders, and I'm part of
the board of Catholics
for the Right to Decide.
But I remember we used to be
girls playing one side and boys
playing on the other side.
And I remember always asking
the question, why is this?
I have brothers and cousins,
and we used to play together
and things were different there.
And I remember the answers
were not quite satisfying.
And then, as I
grew up, my parents
would say like, what do you
want to be when you grow up?
And across the street, there was
a farming school full of boys,
and I thought that
was really cool.
They used to be
outdoors all the time.
And I said, I want
to be a farmer.
I want to that school.
And they would like,
hmm, not really.
That's for boys.
And I was like, why is that?
And again, not a very
satisfying answer to that.
And then, I think all
of it came together
when I was in secondary school
and one of my best friends
got pregnant.
And she wasn't rejected
from our school,
but she couldn't be
part of us anymore.
The social stigma associated
with teen pregnancy is huge,
continues to be huge.
And so I think all
of it came together,
and it was clear that it
could have been any of us.
That we needed the
information to be
able to protect ourselves,
to live healthy lives.
And that it wasn't there.
That wasn't available to us.
I also grew up you know during
the dictatorship in Argentina.
I was born in 1976 in June.
Now you know my age.
And the dictatorship began
in March of that year.
So I remember that
crushing sense
that things would never change.
And then, when democracy
came, that feeling of it
was in our hands to make that
happen and to protect it.
So I think all of it
had to do with ending up
in Planned Parenthood doing
work for women's rights.
I truly believe that there isn't
the possibility of development
without half of the
population being included.
And sexual and public
health and rights are key.
Deciding if we want
to have children,
when we want to have
children, with whom
is critical to us being fully
participants in society.
So all came together there.
DANIELLE BROWN: I love that.
Well, thank you for sharing
your personal story with us.
And I always appreciate that
because it sort of gives
a sense for how you got
to where you are today,
which I think a lot of people
always want to know about.
Tell us a little bit about sort
of the wide range of services
that Planned
Parenthood does provide
and sort of what the population
you serve looks like.
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
Well, we last year alone
served about six million women
in Latin America
and the Caribbean
and provided roughly
30 million services
from pap screening,
cervical cancer screening,
sex education, gender-based
violence services,
access to contraception,
and safe and legal abortion
when that is allowed
by the local laws.
One thing that I
should mention is
that we are a global
federation, so we
have a presence in about 150
countries around the world.
We represent Latin
America and the Caribbean.
We work with 40
independent organizations,
not-for-profit organizations
that are affiliated to us.
I don't know.
How many of you do know
of Planned Parenthood
Federation of America?
Many of you know, right?
Yes, they're our great
partner in the US.
How many of you do know of
IPPF, or International Planned
Parenthood Federation?
Probably not too many.
It's OK.
Planned Parenthood
Federation of America
is our partner in
the US, and like
that we have partners
in 150 countries
globally or so, many
of them providing
full care, comprehensive
sexual and reproductive health
services for women and men.
About 10% of our
services are to men.
And we have a big
focus on youth.
Across the world
and in particularly
in Latin America and
the Caribbean, about 40%
of our services go
to young people.
DANIELLE BROWN: And in
a lot of those cases,
are you providing free
or low-cost health
care to the patients
that come in your door?
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
We not only have clinics
in many of the countries.
There is a game I like
to play when I go.
I spend much of my time
visiting clinics and programs
in Latin America
and the Caribbean.
And when the taxi driver
picks me up from the airport,
I always ask, so do you
know our local clinics?
Have you been there?
Have your friends went there?
And the answer to those
questions normally is yes.
They know our clinics because
we've been providing services
now for 50 years in the region.
But we not only provide the
services in the clinics.
We also run community-based
programs down in communities
where other people will then go.
And all of those areas are
subsidized, and many of them
are free of cost indeed.
DANIELLE BROWN: So probably
for a lot of these women,
especially in rural communities,
that Planned Parenthood clinic
might be the only clinic that
is affordable and accessible
for them.
Is that right?
GISELLE CARINO: Indeed, indeed.
Yes.
DANIELLE BROWN: So you
have the organization
for over a decade, which
is quite impressive.
Can you share what's changed
in that time over your service
with the International
Planned Parenthood Federation?
GISELLE CARINO: Well, you
know, it's interesting.
I am a first-time CEO and
transitioned to become the CEO
last year--
arguably, not the best year
to transition to anything
called Planned Parenthood.
It's a year full of challenges.
And I think my work before
was programmatic work.
I spent time with women
and the communities.
And I think I saw a
great change in them.
So we have been able to lift
many people out of poverty
in Latin America
and the Caribbean.
We still remain as one of
the most unequal regions
in the world.
That means that
if you are young,
if you are poor, if you are
from an indigenous community,
if you are Afro-descendant, the
way you experience life, health
services, your
needs are different.
Most of our countries are
considered now middle-income
countries, and this means
that donors have pulled out
from the region.
But huge pockets of poverty
and inequality remain.
And the people we
serve are these people.
So we need to continue
investing in these program
and in these services.
I think we know that we
have done great advances.
We have been there for 60 years.
We have brought contraception
to many of these countries.
Emergency contraception, what is
called the morning after pill,
it should be called the as soon
as possible because usually you
can use it up to five days
after having unprotected sex.
But the sooner you
use it, the better.
We brought that many
of the countries
in which we are working.
So we have made great strides
in bringing contraception
to women, but we know that
we have 23 million women who
want access to
modern contraception
and don't have it.
So I think there have been
great advances in general,
but there are huge
challenges that remain.
And we have to continue
working to close that gap.
DANIELLE BROWN: For sure.
In Silicon Valley here, we're
technologists by and large.
So we always think about the
role of technology in our work.
So has technology played a role
in the work of International
Planned Parenthood Federation?
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
I think we have made important
investments in technology.
It might seem small
to you, but we
invested in making sure that
we have electronic health
records across the world so
that we can not only serve women
better but also assess the
health outcomes over time.
And that's an investment we
have done over a number of years
now.
We think there are
great opportunities
for technological innovations.
We're a region with
high connectivity,
and we have in front of
us the largest generation
of young people ever.
Reaching them is a
huge opportunity.
It's a huge challenge as well.
And I suspect that
Google will know
how to help us close
that gap because I think
probably technology
has a key role
to play in reaching these
people with both information,
education, and actual services.
Unfortunately,
telemedicine, all of that
is not as developed as
it is here, but we do
follow very closely and love
to try a few innovations
that we know are happening in
the United States right now
and that hold great
potential to bring services
to women in a much more
cost-effective way.
DANIELLE BROWN: That's
a fantastic opportunity
for all of us here to think
about and be involved with,
for sure.
So we do have a powerful
female CEO here in our midst,
and I always like to ask
you a little bit about what
that year has been like and what
are some of the key leadership
challenges you faced
and the lessons you've
learned in that year.
GISELLE CARINO: Well, it
was clearly a tough year.
Not only we had a new US
administration not quite
favorable to our
issues, and everything
that happens in the US
has an impact overseas.
The US used to have a
leadership role on these issues.
That's no longer the case.
And President Trump
imposed as soon
as he took office
the global gag rule.
DANIELLE BROWN:
Talk a little bit
about that because I'm not
sure everybody's familiar.
GISELLE CARINO: Yeah.
Every Republican president since
Reagan put in place something
called the global
gag rule, which
limits the ability of
organizations overseas
that receive US funding to
either advocate for changing
the laws and policies in
relationship to abortion,
to provide abortion services
with their own resources
even if abortion is
legal in that country.
And the money normally
from the US government
was for work like access to
contraception, gender-based
violence.
What Trump did was impose a
rule of really unprecedented
proportions touching
every source of funding
from the US government,
including tuberculosis,
malaria, HIV/AIDS.
So normally, about $600 million
of US foreign assistance money
would be gagged as we call it.
In this case, it's
about $8.8 billion.
So this is a policy
that has the potential
to really do serious damage
to women around the world.
We as an organization
decided not
to be gagged by this policy.
We will give up about
$100 million as a whole.
And we think this rule is unfair
and unjust and harms women
and really has the potential of
harming women across the globe.
So that was a big challenge we
faced as soon as I took office
in, I think, April last year.
We had Brexit in July, and we
had the elections in November.
And this happened
right after in January.
So I think that that was one
of the biggest challenges.
The second one, you
might have heard
we have had a string of
natural disasters affecting
in the region over
the past few months--
again, disasters of
unprecedented proportions.
Our clinics have been
badly affected, our teams.
But it's really amazing to see.
We had the earthquake in Mexico.
The day after, our teams, people
in our office lost their homes.
They show up to work to
provide care for women--
not in the clinics because
the clinics were damaged--
in the streets.
DANIELLE BROWN: Wow.
GISELLE CARINO: Whatever
that was possible,
they were there to
help women because we
know that one of the
things that happens when
natural disasters affect is that
the needs of women and girls
are normally not the priority.
But life goes on.
People continue to
need contraception.
need prenatal care.
And I think it has been amazing
to see the level of response
in spite of such a
difficult situation.
And maybe, if I am
allowed a second
to talk about Puerto Rico.
DANIELLE BROWN: Yes, please.
GISELLE CARINO:
Puerto Rico is a case
that hurts me because the
situation of the island
was dire before
the hurricanes hit.
And 50% of the population
living below the poverty
line, many of them women, and
then we have the hurricanes.
And as you know, the response
from the federal government
has been limited, unsatisfying.
I don't know what objective
to use to define it.
We have four clinics
in the island none
of which are up and running.
DANIELLE BROWN: Still?
GISELLE CARINO: Still because
we don't have electricity.
We raise funding to buy
generators, which is the way.
And it takes a
while for generators
to get there because
obviously everyone
is trying to buy generators.
And you can't keep them
running all the time,
so we have some limitations.
Gas is a problem,
accessing gas to run them.
And we know the need is there.
We have the infrastructure
to serve women.
We need help to get those
clinics back in order
and to provide the services
that are very much needed
because no one else
will be doing that.
So it's I guess a plea of
help for the case of Puerto
Rico in which the response
has been with contempt
and is very much in need.
DANIELLE BROWN: I think
that's a really good point.
And as you point
out, it really has
been such a challenging year--
from policy and politics
and natural disasters.
And I can tell that this
work is very personal,
and it's very emotional.
And I really do applaud your
bravery and your courage
and your leadership.
How do you sort of keep your
staff and your caregivers
and your providers
sort of motivated
to do this work in the long run?
Because it can be
very challenging
and emotional and taxing.
GISELLE CARINO: We hold
tight to the good things.
These people are fighters.
They've been fighting
in the front lines.
These challenges
are not new to us.
Are bigger, that's right.
It's always difficult.
But our teams are there
serving the needs of women.
There is nothing
more satisfying--
there is nothing more satisfying
to me and too many of them--
than when you sit with
women in the waiting rooms
and when I travel
and get to talk
to women, the number
of barriers they
had to overcome to
be there and you have
the answer to what they need.
There is nothing more
satisfying than being
able to provide that.
And I think that holding tight
to that is what keeps us going.
And the support
of so many of you.
We couldn't do this work
without supporters like you
who are there to hold
the line and support
us every step of the way.
So thank you.
Thank you very much.
DANIELLE BROWN: Thank
you, and thank you
for motivating your team
of caregivers and providers
to do this work.
It's really quite incredible.
You talked a little bit
about how often times
when a young woman
gets to your clinic
they've overcome a
lot of barriers just
to get there and be present
that day for their services.
Can you talk a little bit
about some of those barriers
these women face?
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
And we work to help
them overcome them.
I'll talk a little bit
about our cervical cancer
work, which I think is a
good indication of that.
Cervical cancer
is still a killer
for women in Latin
America and the Caribbean
and across the globe.
And it's caused by a virus
called the HPV virus.
There are many
strains of the virus,
but two that really
cause cervical cancer.
And there is a vaccine that
is available in developed
countries.
So we partner with
the Ministry of Health
in Bolivia and our
member association
there to bring their
vaccine to Latin
America and the Caribbean.
And it was quite
pricey at the moment.
And normally here, women--
girls, the vaccination
ranges between I
think nine and 12 years of age--
to the pediatrician.
The pediatrician would
offer the vaccine.
The vaccine has three doses,
so you have to go three times
a year with your
girl for the vaccine.
So when we began looking at this
program, and many of the women
we serve work in the fields,
selling food in the market.
They can't just take
the day off to do this.
They might not have enough money
to feed their family that week
if they do so.
So we developed this initiative
and applied the vaccines
in a pilot program
in the schools
because we know a high
proportion of the girls
are in school.
They don't need
their mothers there.
And we have very successful
rates of vaccination,
higher than any other
vaccination program
in this pilot initiative.
So we tried to bridge
the gap because when
you work in
low-resource settings
we have to be creative and
disruptive in the way we
think through programming.
So that has been, I
think, a very good example
of trying to find
people where they are
and help them overcome the
challenges that they wouldn't
have otherwise.
DANIELLE BROWN:
That's fantastic.
I want to talk a little
bit about a real issue
and a real crisis in
our society, which is
the issue of sexual assaults.
We've seen movements
like metoo start spilling
out to other countries,
and we've definitely
been hearing just more and
more about the prevalence
of sexual assault sort of
to women around the world.
How are you sort of
thinking about that work
and thinking about
educating girls and women
about sexual assault, sexual
violence, sexual harassment,
and the impact of
those things to them?
GISELLE CARINO: You know,
I come from our region
in which one in three women
has suffered violence.
I think of the 25 countries
with highest homicide rates--
feminicide we call
them, against women--
14 are in Latin America
and the Caribbean.
I follow very closely metoo.
I think it's great.
There's it's a lot in
women's storytelling, women
coming forward and
telling their stories.
I think it was very interesting
to see how that had a trickle
effect in about 12 countries.
You have to love the French.
They call it out the pig
or something like that.
I mean, just fabulous.
Very quickly, even in
Argentina a few days
after the Weinstein
case in the US,
we had a case for a
journalist as well.
I think there is a lot of power
in people telling their story
and coming forward.
This is not just
about solidarity.
It's about self-exposure.
And we know, those of us
who have worked in violence,
we know that for every woman
that comes forward there are
at least 10 that haven't.
And there a pervasive
element in our society.
Also, in Argentina, we are
home of a movement called
Ni Una Menos, Not One Less.
This movement kind of
happened organically
as a result of a number of super
high-profile cases of homicides
against women mostly
by their partners.
And we are 40 million,
and they mobilized
about a million people
in the first time
that they got together.
Last year, they mobilized
three million people.
And you could argue
Argentineans like to march,
but I think it was
incredible the mobilization,
the digital mobilization.
Many people show up at work
dressed in black to mourn,
to show their solidarity.
And I think that's amazing.
I think as a movement,
I like to think we
are reaching a tipping point.
We no longer have to accept
this as part of our life.
And I think there is a lot
of transformation going on.
And if there is something to
have faith, confidence on,
it's in the ability
of civil society,
of all of us, keeping
this conversation going.
Because loss and
policies will follow,
but we first need to understand
that this is simply not
acceptable.
We don't have to put
up with this anymore,
and that's the
conversation that I
saw going on that
gets me very excited
because I think this is
the beginning of the end.
DANIELLE BROWN: Which
is a terrific sort
of optimistic view, and I
really thank you for that.
You know, you said something
that really struck me.
You said for every one
woman that comes forward
and reports a sexual
assault or sexual violence,
there is probably 10 more
that haven't reported.
How can technology or how can
our work help more women sort
of be able to come forward
and get the help they
need and the support they need?
GISELLE CARINO: Yeah.
I think it's what we are seeing.
We have been one of the first
institutions that created
a health response to violence.
And I think with technology
so much more can be done.
I think, as I said, it's
very powerful for women
to come forward.
And they have done so.
And up here, this is the
conversation happening,
the regular conversation.
Everybody is talking about this.
And I think technology is
obviously a big part of that.
It couldn't have
happened before.
This is not, I support x.
This is, metoo.
DANIELLE BROWN: Yes.
GISELLE CARINO: I am
very much part of this,
and I think it was possible
because of the connectivity
and the platforms we have to
be able to express ourself.
And I think that's
a great thing.
That's a great thing.
DANIELLE BROWN: For sure.
Tell us a little bit about
how International Planned
Parenthood Federation is
approaching HIV and AIDS--
the treatment, the
care, the awareness--
in the region as well.
GISELLE CARINO: Yeah.
Sexual rights and the
work around HIV/AIDS
have been central to our work.
We integrated HIV detection
services across our region
in Latin America
and the Caribbean.
I have gone to the
communities, worked
with the specific populations
where the virus tends to be
concentrated in the region.
It has been a critical
piece of our work.
Luckily, there has
been a lot of progress
in the region on that issue, and
some of our member associations
even provide treatment--
one of them, Dominican
Republic, for instance.
So we have been fully involved
over the past 10 years
in integrated service
delivery on HIV
and feel very proud of the
accomplishments in that area.
DANIELLE BROWN:
That's wonderful.
I want to turn a little
bit to some of the laws
and policy in the region.
So certainly, even
in the States,
we're seeing laws
and restrictions
being passed that make
it harder to have access
to safe and legal abortion.
Are you seeing that as
well in Latin America
and the Caribbean?
GISELLE CARINO: Thank
you for that question
because, when I talked
earlier about service delivery
and education, I forgot
to mention that we really
work around laws and policies
that inhibit access for women's
exercise of their rights.
We work at the local,
at the regional,
and we also head
the work at the UN
on behalf of IPPF
as a whole globally.
What we are seeing
in Latin America,
we have a lot of
laws and policies.
The issue, the
hardest nut to crack,
is in the implementation
aspects of things
and making sure that
the money exists
to support service delivery.
We are still home to
four countries who
have a total ban on abortion.
And for those of you who
might not know what that is,
it's that you can't
access abortion services
in any circumstances, not even
to preserve your own life.
So it's a big challenge we have.
I remember the case
of [? Eperanza. ?]
She was a 16-year-old from
the Dominican Republic
who was pregnant and had cancer,
and her treatment for cancer
was denied because
of her pregnancy.
It would put a risk
to her pregnancy.
And in the Dominican Republic,
along with El Salvador,
Nicaragua, and Honduras,
there are no exceptions.
So she died.
She paid with her life.
The Congress is
still debating a bill
to open some legal exceptions,
but there is much work
to be done in that regard.
We have a number
of countries that
have legal exceptions
on the books,
but those have not materialized
in the life of women.
They might exist on paper, but
the implementation of those
is oftentimes limited.
And oftentimes, we are one of
the providers in those places
in which a legal exception
exists for abortion care,
for legal abortion
care for women.
We just had a big window.
There was a total ban
on abortion in Chile,
and we just, I want
to say two months ago,
were able to pass
a legislation that
allows for three
legal exceptions--
to preserve the
life of the woman,
for cases of rape
and incest, and cases
of fetal malformations
incompatible with life.
And the law is limited in scope.
It's only three circumstances.
It was a legacy from the
Pinochet dictatorship.
But it's a big step
forward for Chilean women
to be able to access
in these circumstances.
And we still have
four more countries
to be able to overturn
the total bans.
We have the case--
I don't know if you have
heard or follow the news-- we
have the case of El Salvador.
Women in El Salvador
go to jail, if they
are suspected of having had
a miscarriage, for 30 years.
So these are really
are draconian laws that
need to change.
And they need to be
changed definitely.
DANIELLE BROWN: And so I
imagine a lot of your work
as the CEO of the International
Planned Parenthood
Federation in the
Western Hemisphere
is working with policy
makers, influencing,
lobbying for change.
How are you finding
the receptivity
to these issues and
their willingness
to understand the issues,
learn and adapt, change?
GISELLE CARINO: We have, I
think, great partnerships
with the governments.
We have local organizations
that are leading
the work on the ground just
PPFA is leading the work here
in the US.
That helps because
the organizations
have been there for 60 years.
They have a reputation.
They know what we do.
Having said that,
these issues are hard.
And as I said, it's not
only just changing the laws.
Once the laws change,
the real fight begins.
And the fight is making
sure that those services
are available to women.
So we also act as watchdogs
for the government
to make sure that the
laws are implemented
and quite importantly
that there is funding
to support the provision
of those services
in the national budgets.
Because, at the
end, we are there
to support as long,
as much as we can.
But this needs to be part
of the country program.
And that's easier
said than done.
When it comes to
the reality, we have
laws that have been on the
books for 100 years now.
Implementation is slow.
It's a hard fight, but I
think one worth fighting.
DANIELLE BROWN: Very much so.
I think you said something
that probably-- it's definitely
surprised me and maybe
some of our audience, too--
is that there's a big
difference between getting
a law passed and the practical
implementation of it.
And I think sometimes
as activists
we think our work is done
when the law is passed.
So the laws is passed, and
change magically happens.
And I think you're
saying, hey, there's
actually a long
road between a law
on the books and practical
implementation on the ground.
Are there steps that can
be taken to sort of shorten
that gap between passing a law
and practically implementing it
for the folks you serve?
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
We think in our experience
working with health care teams
in building the
support for the new law
is critical because you've
got to have providers who
are ready to provide services.
Not only ready, ideologically
ready, technically.
So I think we have learned
that, if you engage health care
providers from the get-go,
not only they work with women,
they know their stories.
They can bring their stories
to the public conversation.
But also, they are the ones who
will have to provide services.
And that has proved to be, I
think, an important element
that we have learned
through the work
we have done in the region.
DANIELLE BROWN: Yeah.
That's very insightful.
Thank you.
John, I just wanted to take
a look, check with you.
Are there questions
from the door?
I certainly have a
lot more for Giselle,
but I want to make sure
audience gets their questions.
AUDIENCE: We do
indeed have a couple.
DANIELLE BROWN: Great.
AUDIENCE: Start
with one of them.
Molly asks, "I used to
work in public health
in sub-Saharan Africa.
One of the challenges
I encountered
was combating
dangerous myths about
reproductive and sexual health.
How do you correct these
misconceptions in the field,
and is there
anything we at Google
can do to combat this
type of misinformation?"
GISELLE CARINO: Of course.
I mean, I think we
heard it all in terms
of myths and misconceptions
about contraception,
about everything else.
I think I could not
stress enough the need
to have comprehensive
sexual education
for young people and as
early as that is possible.
And not any type of
comprehensive sexual education,
but one that is evidence
based, that talks about power
and relationships, that
helps kids, young people
maneuver their life and
their relationships,
and to help them challenge the
social norms around masculinity
that are oftentimes the basis
for machismo and for violence.
I think that's critical.
I think you at Google can help.
As I said, we have the
biggest opportunity ever.
We have the largest generation
of young people in front of us.
Reaching them with the right
information, it's critical.
And I suspect you
will have ideas
on how you can help us do that.
But it's definitely
something that
will be an investment that will
pay off in the next 40 years.
We know education pays off.
Comprehensive sexual education
is not the exception to that.
We have plenty of evidence of
that type of sexual education
that works.
And I think we just need
to be able to reach kids
in school, out of school
with good information
so they can actually live
the life they want to live.
And I think it's
critical that we do that.
DANIELLE BROWN: That's
a great question.
Thank you, Molly.
Another one, John?
AUDIENCE: One more, actually
following along that one.
"Can you talk a bit about how
you evaluate your programs
for effectiveness?"
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
For every program we run, we do
an evaluation of the program.
Also, each member
association runs evaluation
of their own programs as well.
Evaluation is critical
for learning for us.
And I think the program I
was talking about in Bolivia
on cervical cancer is again
a good example because we not
only look about effectiveness--
is the vaccine effective,
is effective in this setting--
we also look at, are
there better ways?
Are the more cost-effective
effective ways of doing that?
One thing that we are
very happy to know now
is that the vaccine
that I was talking about
to prevent cervical cancer,
instead of having three doses,
have two doses.
Being able to deliver a program
with two doses as opposed
to three might
seem a small thing.
It's a huge thing because
in low-resource settings,
if you can eliminate one
step, keep the same results,
you can use that
money for other health
pressing needs in the country.
So we would love
to do much more,
but we have a commitment to
evaluate everything we do.
DANIELLE BROWN:
That's fantastic.
You know, one issue we haven't
touched too much on yet
is maternal mortality.
And I'd love to understand
sort of the prevalence
or the demographics
in your region
around maternal mortality
and sort of a little bit
about the harm reduction
model that sort of really
helps address that issue.
Can you talk to us about that?
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
Thank you for that question.
The harm reduction model
was developed in Uruguay
about 10 years ago by a
group of midwives and doctors
who worked in a public hospital.
And maternal
mortality was always
relatively low in Uruguay
with one exception,
which was maternal mortality
due to unsafe abortion.
And what happens
in the region is
that, if you are
a woman of means,
even though the law might
not allow for legal abortion
you can get an abortion
from your doctor.
The problem is that those
who are not women of means
simply die from unsafe abortion.
So this is what they
face in Uruguay.
They thought at the moment
that abortion was restricted.
There were a few exceptions
not really known by women
and not really used
by providers either.
And abortion had a moment, but
it also had a before and an
after where women had
contacts with their providers.
And doing nothing wasn't
what they wanted to do.
So they developed a model that
allows them to educate women
about what they shouldn't
do if they decide
to pursue an abortion, what not
to insert, the warning signs,
and also to come back
for care afterwards.
They couldn't probably
help them in the moment--
only if they were eligible
for the legal exceptions,
otherwise they didn't have
the ability to help them.
But help them with education,
and they could come back
for care when they need care.
Post-abortion care is legal
in a lot of the countries.
And they thought this
was very important.
At the same time, there was
a new drug called Misoprostol
that became available
in the region,
and it's a drug
that saves lives.
Women can induce abortions.
It's much safer.
And so providers
would educate women
on how to use Misoprostol.
They couldn't tell them
where to get Misoprostol
or they couldn't
prescribe the drug,
but based on the right
to access information
they thought women should have
access to the best information
to preserve their lives.
And this is how they
build the model.
And quite interesting,
the model was
expanded to several countries
in Latin America and in Africa.
And they dropped maternal
mortality to zero
in a matter of ten years.
And they also paved the way, I
think, for abortion law reform.
Uruguay in 2012 passed a law
that decriminalized abortion up
to 12 weeks in the country.
And I am absolutely convinced
that talking to women,
educating providers was
key to build support
around the need of a law that
would allow women to manage
this part of their lives with
safety and with good health
outcomes.
So I think the model was
portrayed in "The New York
Times," and very much
we are proud that they
were able to create and
have a role to play in such
a moment in women's lives.
DANIELLE BROWN: Sure.
Certainly, getting maternal
mortality down to 0%
is an amazing feat,
so thank you for that.
We talked a little bit about
the laws and the restrictions
that you're seeing
sort of come up
in Latin America
and the Caribbean,
but talk a little
bit about certainly
in the US over the
past several years
there's been a lot of
restrictive laws passed
making it harder to access
contraception, access
safe and legal abortion.
How does sort of the
policy in the United States
and the arguments and politics
sort of around women's health
impact the work you
do in the region?
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
The US used to be a
place where we looked up
for leadership on these issues.
And as I said, that's
no longer the case.
But in addition to that, and
in addition to the global gag
rule that I talked
before that really
curtails the possibility of
organizations to serve women,
I say that what we
are beginning to see
is a much stronger violent
and aggressive opposition
in the region,
which is quite new.
We had not seen that before.
In a matter of a
few months, we had
our offices vandalized
in one of the countries,
our executive director in
another country with death
threats, and things that we
clearly had not seen before.
We also have something that came
up in Colombia that is called
[? Agenda ?] [? Ideology, ?] a
whole reframing conversation.
And it came right at the
moment of the peace process
and against all of our
issues really very strongly.
And I think we have to think
about as a clear influence
there has been some
reports recently,
I think in "The
Guardian" about the role
of the opposition in the
US funding the opposition
in many of the Latin American
and Caribbean countries.
And I think we are going to
see more of that in the years
to come.
DANIELLE BROWN: So
really, the work
we all do in our
individual regions
and countries really
is interconnected.
And so playing a
role to actively
advocate for policies that
advance women's health
are important for all of us.
GISELLE CARINO: Yes, absolutely.
Very much, very much.
DANIELLE BROWN: John, any
last questions from the Dory,
as I ask Giselle just a few
last important questions.
AUDIENCE: There was
one last one, which
was a lot of the conversation
around Planned Parenthood is
on the topic of abortion,
but I understand
you put an awful lot of effort
into other kinds of services
as well.
Could you perhaps touch
on a couple of those?
GISELLE CARINO: Yes.
If you look at
our annual report,
abortion services are about
5% of the services we provide.
About 30% are services
on contraception,
cancer screening, gender-based
violence detection
and screening and support.
So when you look at the
number of services we provide
and the division,
you'll see that it's
a very small proportion.
We feel very proud of the
work we do on abortion,
but we do much more indeed.
And as I said, we have
been leaders in accessing,
in bringing contraception to
Latin America and the Caribbean
and have done so for
about 60 years now.
So yes, we provide
comprehensive care to women.
We feel we need to serve the
needs of women, all of them
with no exceptions when it
comes to reproductive and sexual
care.
And that's how we stand
as an organization,
and that can be easily
verified by our annual report.
It hasn't changed much
over the years really.
DANIELLE BROWN: I think that's a
great reminder of the resources
available to us to learn
about Planned Parenthood
and the wide range
of work you all do.
So at Google here,
we're coming up
on our annual Giving Week
Googlers are very involved
in giving back to the
communities we serve
and communities around the
world through our time,
through our money.
What is the best way
for a Googler who
is interested in women's health
and reproductive freedom, what
is the best way for
Googlers to get involved?
GISELLE CARINO: Well,
first, thank you, Googlers.
We feel your love.
We are really very
happy to count
with us one of our supporters.
I think the first thing I
would say, become a supporter.
Donate to us.
You can do so through
our website, IPPFWHR.org.
This is the moment.
If non of the arguments
before convinced you,
this is the moment to
double down on women's right
to reach the birth, to support
all of the progressive causes.
There is no best
time to do that now
because so much is under threat.
We just learned that you
also have a program that you
can spend your time with us.
We would love.
I think you have a lot
of ideas and thoughts
that could be very useful to us.
And I think, finally,
again, you can
help us bridge the gap in the
most difficult issues we are
facing and will make a
difference in the next 50 years
in the region.
So I'd love to engage in the
conversation on how that could
help in accessing young
people, working together
to be able to enable that.
So I think there are many ways.
And of course, collaborating and
supporting your local Planned
Parenthood as well.
We are a global
movement, and the support
is needed everywhere.
DANIELLE BROWN:
That's fantastic.
So I want to end
on a positive note.
You did talk about it is a
challenging time for women's
reproductive rights, for
issues of health care,
for sexual violence and
assault. But in talking to you,
I can tell that you
have a lot of hope
and a lot of optimism
for a better future.
And can you tell us
sort of maybe a story
or share a few
thoughts about sort
of how you keep that hope and
optimism alive in this work
which is so important?
GISELLE CARINO: It's
difficult, Danielle.
There are days in which I don't
feel necessarily this way.
I think we have to keep
an eye on the long fight.
We've been here for 60 years.
We'll be here for 60 more.
We are not going to
give up on women.
And we have seen the
change that happens.
And if one keeps their
eye on that long game,
we know things are possible
and change will come.
It will require a lot of effort.
It's a back and forth.
It's never a straight
line to the finish.
There is never a finish.
But I have a lot of confidence
in the role of civil society
organizations,
organizations like ours,
who will not give up.
And I think it's
very clear to us
that this is a fight worth
fighting if anything.
So yeah, that keeps me going.
DANIELLE BROWN: Well,
Giselle, I've got to tell you,
I think you instilled a great
deal of hope and optimism
for me today certainly and I
know for our audience members.
And I just want to
thank you for that.
I think we touched on a lot of
issues today and I think really
gave Googlers listening
and the world listening
a sense of sort of some of
the issues that we're facing
and the importance
of getting involved.
So I just want to thank you.
We're very grateful for
you and your knowledge
and, most importantly, your
hope and your optimism.
So thank you.
GISELLE CARINO:
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]